le gros chat a
manger la petite souris c'est compris
bon et bien la brèche tenez la
brèche allez-y la
brèche
le
on ne souffle pas ég gr
madame c'est bien la brche c'est bien je
vous aurez neu et de bons
points
madameadame
merci
Suou vous pouvez me répéter ce que je
viens de dire là mais madame on
éécoutait pas su r comme d'habitude mais
madame vous allez aller au piquet vous
ranger de
bâton au
piquame mais il n'y a pas de ma madame
voilà de jours que vous devriez savoir
le gros chat a mangé la petite souris et
vous n'êtes pas capable de le lire au
piquet
madame oui l'or madame et ben tout à
l'heure il faisait rien que de
Copi c'est bien
l'or c'est bien dénoncer ces méchants
petit camarad oui
madame vous aurez trois doubl
bonad
madame malfruche madameoiselle au
tableau
malfuch
fruche vous allez m'écrire la phrase
suivante et chacun l'écrit sur son
cahier de
[Applaudissements]
dicté ramasserez les cahers à la fin de
l'heure alors dicté tout le monde est
prêt dicté prê quand les
chevox quand les chevaux
mir leur
sabot h sa bot avec sur la
terte du petit on ne bave pas quand on
écrit he la brèche quand on écrit à la
brèche sur la tête du petit canari
ça
fait
SPL
allons-y vite section C 5 et 7 angle du
boulevard Saint-Germain et du boulevard
Saint-Michel numéro
8y et celui-là celui-là il est au piqué
il fait ses bâtons capitaine parfait il
prendra la tête merci ally mon petit
mais vous savez capitaine que si vous me
les enlevez tous les quart d'heur ils ne
seront jamais ni lire ni écrire ah
serviteur
[Musique]